hello guys Ryan Wright here today I want
to talk about the debate that I've been
reflecting on I have to say I agree with
some things that jacksFilms aka Jack
Douglas said during his debate with jinx
about our reaction channels you know
stealing content or is it wrong what
reaction channels do I want to establish
that I have not seen any of Jack's films
videos the only one I saw was him
reacting in jinxes video so I got a
snippet of Jack's film in jinxes video
however after it was done I didn't
really care to click on the link to the
original video I know a lot of the time
people do but I don't think most of the
time people do hey because most of what
I check out is primarily requested
videos and they're requested because
people have already seen them they're
still gonna be those people who haven't
seen the original video now if they come
across it they're gonna feel like oh I
already saw this during this person's
reaction now I know there's a lot of
things that separate this channel from
being part of a typical reaction channel
these days yes there tends to be guests
like not all the time but usually
there's a guest and I know for damn sure
that we try that we do our best to
provide entertainment before the
reaction for like thirty Seconds to a
minute and then after the reaction
providing a discussion or a review and
also throwing in some fun [ __ ] in there
by doing that I know that that is
providing content that's providing
insight that's providing a discussion
most of the time what I love most people
are not saying great reaction Oh
wonderful reaction most people if you
look at our comment boxes are commenting
on the discussion after the reaction if
you look at most reactors sorry say this
but most of the time they are only being
commenting on about their reaction not
anything saying afterwards so I know
that separates us from a lot of others
I'll say oh I'm the only one that does
it but that separates us from the
majority of the complaints however for
the reaction portion I got to agree with
Jack that
I have always been not 100% comfortable
with using the full video
unless of course like you know when it's
a video where you got no choice but you
got to show the whole reaction because
the whole thing is totally worth it but
if it's not like there are videos where
I know I'm just a [ __ ] blank face
while something it's like it can be
boring to watch that when I could just
tell you guys after the video like yeah
it wasn't that into it instead of just
watching me not be into it it could be
more fun if I if I if on those kind of
videos I hopped around the highlights so
what I'm saying is I'm trying to find
that happy medium between the
subscribers who want the full reaction
and the subscribers who want it to just
be highlights for certain videos like if
you check out I don't know what's one
where the whole reaction was worth like
our first Star Wars video reaction
review the hatred first gameplay
reaction review that I did with damn
like that one is the one where I show
the whole reaction and I won't want to
hop around that one I know there's gonna
be certain ones where you can't hop
around them like I try not to laugh I
imagine for a try not to laugh you can't
really hop around because that's a
challenge video you got it like it's a
challenge for you to not laugh or
something so you want to see the whole
video of that that makes sense and
usually the people who compose to try
not to laughs and the vine compilations
whatever they tend to be okay with
people using their content for that
because it's kind of like a challenge
video I know a lot of people are
actually really cool with reacting to
their whole video you know I've been
contacted by people to react to their
whole video I've been contacted by
people after I've reacted to their video
I know a lot of people are tend to be
like [ __ ] awesome like ten second
songs totally cool with it and like that
and they wanted to do some type of
collab actually that I what happened to
that for a lot of trailers you know they
tend to be cool some trailers are like
no no but even when it's see there's
there's there's copyright strikes and
then there's match third party content
next third party content means ads won't
display on the video we
real rejects won't generate any type of
money from it other than there will be
viewership so it's view count but the
view count won't equal to any type of
Commission earning you know there's a
chance to gain some subscribers too but
ads will still play because the content
creators are like yeah that's our
content but we like the video so we're
gonna keep it out there you just can't
make money from it unfortunately so that
is like I never dispute that I don't I
agree with that and the reason I don't
do try not to laughs a lot in buying
compilations is because there's nothing
really to discuss afterwards there's not
much commentary you can really give
afterwards I try not to laugh I get it
but for vine compilations it's like I
don't know like when I know it's gonna
be just a reaction that's when I feel
like I'm being pretty lazy to be honest
what I'm suggesting is for certain
videos I will only show highlights not
all them but certain videos probably the
majority might turn into that where I
primarily show highlights of the video
I'm gonna be more on top of it of
putting video links to the original
video in the description box but there's
still be some videos where it's the
whole [ __ ] reaction because I know
some people want to see all that and
some people want to like their
subscribers who just want it to be
highlights and their subscribers who
want it to be the whole thing every time
so this is my way of meeting you guys in
the medium here so distracted by that
and what was I talking about
this would be my way of meeting you guys
in the medium that way you know because
there's a lot of subs who want the
highlights especially now after hearing
the debate and then there's a lot of
subs who want to keep it at the full
length all I'm suggesting is there's
gonna be some videos when I feel the
reaction for the most part would not be
entertaining to watch if it was the
whole reaction then I'm going to only do
highlights of it if I feel like the
whole reaction could be entertaining
then I will keep it and hopefully those
people are cool with it if a reaction is
primarily not much genuine reaction
going on because I don't like faking the
reaction part I try to be as genuine as
possible but when I know I'm like barely
reacting that's when I start feeling
like should I do something more
should I make a comment or something
because people are gonna watch this
whole reaction so I feel like those ones
that I highlight will be will be more
genuine actually because of the fact
that I'll feel more comfortable to just
be really genuine and not worry at all
like if I have a blank face for a while
of trying to change my face for you guys
you know let's be honest and everyone
who does reactions a lot of the time
you're just engrossed in the video and
you're comfortable with the camera
looking at you but you know when you're
not reacting because the video is not
organically giving you something to feel
that way about you start going like what
other emotion am i feeling that I could
work off of here based off the vision
you know so rather than just letting it
be subconscious so yeah that's what I
wanted to say I want it those are the
thoughts I have after listening to the
video and I want to say this video is in
no way an attack on jinx I know that it
was a debate I'm not siding with anyone
but I am saying that there are things
that Jack said that I really do agree
with and I felt those changes should be
implemented in some of our videos and
jinx have nothing against the guy he's a
cool guy I've talked to him several
times and I'll see if you guys want me
to point out something that I felt was
kind of unfair to jinx is he's giving
his subscribers what they want he's
using the full video because the
subscribers that he has want him to
watch the whole video and they want to
see the reaction to the whole video now
I get if Jack is like well it's not
entertaining totally fine if Jack feels
that way however it's like yes I agree
that on some of the videos that it
should just be highlights however I
don't agree that jinx is like doing it
wrong because jinx is just doing what
his subscribers want him to do which is
react to the whole video and my
subscribers I feel are kind of in a mix
of like just doing highlights and
showing the whole reaction but I think
I'll just depend on the video that it is
anyway yeah that was my little two cents
after the debate changes are going to be
implemented and you know what I mean a
lot if
you are new to this channel or if you
subscribe and haven't checked out other
stuff I would love it if you guys check
out like our other content cuz I'll be
honest we put more work into those than
the reaction videos like the movie
reviews a lot of thought goes into the
reviews not exactly like crazy editing
tricks but just the actual content of
discussing the movie like I prep for
those and we got vlogs and we got
sketches or sketches like our last one
in between takes with Ryan and brandy I
have a whole crew and everything we put
a lot of work into that one it was my
first time directing so it's not like
the most beautifully captured piece of
work but it's still like hey a lot of
work went into this anyway guys thanks
for tuning in if you're new to the
channel subscribe today I think this is
on the red side yet subscribe today
become a reject because being a reject
will not mean you're an outcast anymore
because there's other rejects heads no
one's really a reject because everyone
is now part of something so they're not
really being rejected Shay bloom with
another word to call the fans